Transcription: Mohand Habchi
Relecteur: eric vautier
Il y a très longtemps,
je suis invitée par une amie à un dîner,
la soirée est merveilleuse,
il y a plein de monde dans son jardin,
et son époux qui est plutôt
quelqu'un de réservé d'habitude,
ce soir-là, est vraiment
très présent parmi nous.
Il distribue les verres,
les plateaux, les petits fours,
et puis il donne à chacun
un mot gentil, une petite blague.
Le lundi suivant,
j'ai rendez-vous avec mon amie,
je l'attends,
elle tarde un peu,
il y a un coup de fil,
et quand je décroche,
j'entends sa voix qui est
complètement paniquée,
elle me dit : « Mon mari, mon mari.
C'est grave, c'est très, très grave »,
et elle raccroche.
Ce lundi-là, son mari s'est suicidé.
Je suis pétrifiée, sans voix,
incapable de penser à
ce qui vient d'arriver,
et même plus tard, incompétente
pour pouvoir soutenir mon amie
qui est brisée de douleur.
Ce samedi et ce coup de fil
sont gravés dans ma mémoire.
Je suis soignante dans un hôpital,
et en 2000, l'état confie
à mon établissement
une mission de santé publique
sur la prévention du suicide.
Tout de suite, je me sens concernée.
Je postule et je suis retenue.
Malgré mon métier de soignante,
j'accompagne déjà des personnes
qui ont fait des tentatives de suicide,
je découvre l'ampleur du problème.
Aujourd'hui en France, tous les ans,
il y a 10 500 personnes qui se suicident.
C'est trois fois plus que
les accidents de la voie publique
dont on nous parle très souvent à
la télé, à chaque départ en vacances,
et de ces drames, pas grand chose.
Sans compter les 160 000 tentatives
de suicide accueillies tous les jours,
tous les ans, dans les hôpitaux,
et peut-être beaucoup plus d'ailleurs,
parce que tout le monde
n'arrive pas à l'hôpital.
Nous sommes un des pays européens
le plus touché par ces drames.
Alors en 2000,
avec un programme de prévention,
il n'existe pas grand chose
en matière d'information grand public.
Et dans ce programme de prévention avec
plein de grands objectifs à atteindre,
mais pas trop le mode d'emploi,
je vais à la rencontre des milieux
susceptibles de traverser ces drames.
Alors je vais dans les lycées, dans
les collèges, dans les universités,
dans les établissements
pour personnes âgées,
dans les milieux du travail,
et même dans les prisons.
Et partout, partout on me dit :
« Vous êtes gentille, madame,
mais pas chez nous. »
Comme si en parler portait malheur.
Ou alors on me dit : « Mais
on ne peut rien faire pour eux.
On ne peut pas les aider. »
Alors, ces personnes seraient-elles
donc des extraterrestres ?
Non,
parce que penser au suicide, c'est humain.
Les animaux ne se suicident pas.
Ils n'ont pas cette capacité à penser
qu'un jour, ils ne seront plus là
ou à projeter un acte sur eux-mêmes.
Tous les chercheurs
en arrivent à cette conclusion,
et vous voyez, même les dauphins
qui s'échouent sur les plages
ne sont pas des suicides.
Seul l'homme est capable
de porter un acte sur lui-même,
mais quand il souffre, terriblement...
parce qu'on ne peut pas
être bien et passer à l'acte.
Alors évidemment, les idées suicidaires,
elles n'arrivent pas d'un seul coup.
Les personnes traversent
des situations adverses, des difficultés,
qui font que ça va faire
douleur pour eux,
et quand ces idées commencent à
se mettre en place dans la tête des gens,
ils commencent à nous envoyer
des signaux de détresse.
Et puis quelquefois,
ces idées, elles vont
prendre toute la place
et elles vont devenir
une solution possible
pour arrêter leur souffrance.
Et là, la pression est
tellement intense à l'intérieur,
leur douleur psychique tellement forte,
qu'ils sont comme une cocotte-minute
dont on a verrouillé le sifflet,
prête à exploser,
et ce moment est extrêmement
dangereux pour eux.
Mais ce qu'il faut comprendre,
c'est que ce n'est pas
eux qu'ils veulent tuer,
c'est leur souffrance,
et ce que l'on sait aujourd'hui,
c'est que c'est une crise,
et que cette crise,
elle est temporaire et réversible,
et que nous pouvons agir avant.
Oui mais voilà,
en matière de suicide,
ce qui tue le plus, c'est le tabou
et les représentations que
nous avons de ce problème.
Nous portons tous le fardeau, le poids,
d'un interdit social et divin,
depuis des siècles,
qui a contribué
à faire qu'aujourd'hui
nous ayons encore
des représentations sur cette douleur.
Et combien de fois nous entendons :
« Ceux qui en parlent ne le feront pas. »
Huit personnes sur dix
qui se sont suicidées,
en ont parlé
ou ont témoigné de leur
souffrance par leur comportement.
Combien de fois nous entendons
aussi : « C'est un acte lâche. »
C'est une question de désespoir,
la perte de l'espoir.
Combien de fois nous entendons aussi :
« C'est son choix. »
Mais comment peut-on choisir
quand on est perdu dans la douleur ?
Et nous entendons aussi :
« Ce n'est qu'un appel au secours. »
Alors bien sûr, ça nous rassure,
mais quelquefois, ça banalise.
Oui, c'est un appel « Au secours ! »,
et nous appelons « Au secours ! »
à chaque fois que n'avons plus
les moyens de nous aider nous-mêmes.
Alors, qu'est-ce qui nous empêche
d'envoyer la bouée de sauvetage ?
Eh bien, nous avons peur.
Peur de cette souffrance que
nous ne pouvons pas mesurer,
parce qu'elle ne saigne pas
et on ne peut pas faire une prise de sang
pour savoir à combien
cette personne souffre.
Alors du coup, on doute et on se dit :
« Peut-être que cette
personne nous manipule ? »
Peur de ce qu'elle nous renvoie,
ces idées de mort,
ce que nous voudrions tous oublier.
Alors, au lieu de l'entendre
et de l’écouter, nous lui disons :
« Il ne faut pas penser à ça. »
Peur de ne pas savoir
quoi faire, quoi dire.
Peur d'avoir à régler ses problèmes.
Alors on se dit :
« Ça ne nous regarde pas.
C'est une affaire de spécialiste. »
Et pourtant, ces personnes,
elles sont à côté de nous.
Alors comment sortir de cette impasse ?
Comment lui tendre la main,
et qu'elle, elle puisse la saisir ?
Eh bien la seule, la seule issue,
c'est d'en parler,
et pour cela, il faut que
nous fassions ce pas de côté,
se décaler,
se débarrasser de tout ce qui
fait frein pour la rencontrer,
de tout ce qui va fausser notre jugement.
Et puis aussi, il faut
enlever toutes nos casquettes,
de professeur, de chef
d'équipe, de patron,
d'intervenant à domicile, de voisin,
pour pouvoir aller à la rencontre
de cette personne
et mettre en place ce que
nous savons tous faire :
la rencontre d'un humain
qui a besoin d'un autre humain
et qui se soucie de lui.
Et cette rencontre, nous
pouvons tous la faire.
[La] douleur psychique de ces personnes,
il faut que nous puissions la comprendre,
et pour cela, vous savez,
en douleur physique par exemple,
nous avons des réglettes,
très simples, de zéro à dix,
et nous demandons aux gens :
« A combien vous avez mal ? »
et en fonction de ce que
les gens nous disent,
nous leur faisons confiance
et nous adaptons les soins
ou les antalgiques
pour pouvoir atténuer leur douleur.
Eh bien, en douleur psychique,
c'est la même chose.
A zéro on va bien,
à cinq, on commence à aller mal,
et puis à dix, la personne
est en danger vital.
Et pour mettre en place cette
rencontre avec cette personne,
cette relation d'un humain
à un autre humain,
il va falloir entendre, écouter ce
qu'elle est en train de nous dire,
déverrouiller doucement
le sifflet de la cocotte-minute
afin qu'elle puisse
libérer ses tensions,
et ne pas hésiter à
lui poser la question :
« Je vous sens très mal.
Souffrez-vous au point
d'avoir des idées suicidaires ? »
Oui, idées suicidaires.
Tout le monde comprend ce mot.
On ne peut pas se tromper sur le sens.
Qu'on soit jeune ou vieux, on le comprend.
Ça vous fait peur ?
Et pourtant,
ça ne lui contaminera
pas l'idée si elle n'en a pas,
et au mieux, vous aurez vérifié.
Si la personne n'en
a pas, elle vous dira :
« Ah non, je ne vais pas bien, mais
pas à ce point-là quand même. »
Par contre, si elle en a,
mais quel soulagement pour
elle d'avoir quelqu'un en face
qui entende et qui comprenne
cette douleur sans la juger.
Alors évidemment, si elle
en a, il va falloir la protéger,
mettre en place un filet
de sécurité autour d'elle,
le temps de cette crise,
et puis qu'ensuite elle aille mieux.
Un autre exemple.
Vous est-il arrivé déjà
quelquefois dans la rue
de voir quelqu'un tomber devant vous ?
En général, on ne va pas l'enjamber.
On va s’arrêter, même
si on a un rendez-vous,
et puis on va se mettre à sa hauteur,
on va regarder ce qui se passe,
et on ne va pas hésiter
à lui poser la question :
« Est-ce que vous avez mal ? »
Et en fonction de la réponse,
vous allez pouvoir donner
une simple réassurance,
quelquefois appeler de
l'entourage, de la famille,
ou carrément appeler les pompiers.
Eh bien aujourd'hui,
sur le risque suicidaire,
c'est ce que nous aimerions faire,
que tout le monde puisse agir
sur ces premiers secours.
Parce que tout à l'heure, quand
cette personne est tombée,
est-ce qu'elle a fait un accident
vasculaire cérébral,
un accident cardiaque,
une chute de tension ?
ou simplement trébuché
sur un caillou ? ça, on le saura,
mais ça, ce sont des spécialistes
qui iront dire ce qui s'est passé.
Mais notre simple présence,
ce que nous avons fait à ce moment-là,
nous avons gagné du temps sur la vie,
et nous pouvons peut-être tous le faire.
C'est le challenge que nous
avons aujourd'hui en France,
dans le cadre d'un programme
national de prévention du suicide.
Et chaque jour, mes collègues et moi,
sur la région Poitou-Charentes,
nous formons, nous informons,
nous sensibilisons,
des policiers, des patrons,
des intervenants à domicile,
des secrétaires, des DRHs,
des gardiens d'immeuble,
des citoyens,
des bénévoles d'association,
pour que toutes ces personnes
puissent changer leur regard,
puissent ne plus avoir peur d’intervenir
auprès d'une personne qui va mal.
Et s'il y a quatorze ans,
les portes se fermaient,
eh bien aujourd'hui,
le chemin commence à s'ouvrir.
Et quelquefois,
je reçois un coup de fil
ou un message ou un email,
celui de Maryse par exemple.
Maryse est une enseignante à l'université,
et puis elle était venue un jour, comme ça,
sur une journée de sensibilisation,
et elle me disait que son regard avait
profondément changé sur cette douleur.
Et un jour, dans la promotion
dont elle s'occupait,
elle avait repéré un jeune homme
qui n'était pas comme d'habitude.
Et là, elle s'est autorisée
à aller vers lui
et à lui dire qu'elle
se souciait pour lui,
et elle n'a pas hésité
à lui poser la question.
Et en effet, ce jeune homme
avait des idées suicidaires.
Alors elle a pu le mettre en sécurité,
et quand il est allé mieux,
il lui a dit qu'elle
lui avait sauvé la vie.
Nous pouvons tous être des Maryse,
et nous gagnerons des vies.
Ne banalisons jamais une idée suicidaire,
il n'y a que le silence qui tue.
Je vous remercie.
(Applaudissements)